Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
In this video, we're following on from our
installation and overview guide of Tetragon,
an eBPF
security and observability tool
for your Kubernetes cluster.
In this video, we're going to go a
little bit deeper than the installation and a
general overview,
and we're gonna look at one of the
main use cases for adopting Tetragon within your
clusters,
and that is runtime enforcement and observability
of file access across
your container workloads and the host they run
on.
So
let's get into the docs and have some
fun.
Alright. Here we are at the Tetragon documentation
or at least we will be now.
Now there's a few things I want to
cover before we get to the use cases
and the documentation itself well covers file name
access and what we can do.
But there is a little bit of vocabulary
that you have to be comfortable with and
a few concepts that you need to know
before you should really start writing tracing policies.
Fortunately, the documentation has us pretty well covered
too. So if we go to concepts,
tracing policy,
we can now begin to dive in to
what a tracing policy is composed of.
So the first thing that every tracing policy
needs is a hook point.
A hook point can be one of three
things.
First, a k probe. This is a kernel
probe that allows you to hook in to
functions called within the kernel.
Second,
we have u probes.
These are user probes. Go figure.
And these allow you to hook in to
any function called within a user land binary.
And lastly, we have trace points.
These are more generalized points within the kernel
that you can hook into that are stable
across kernel versions.
Like the documentation says,
going from kernel version to kernel version, k
probes are not guaranteed to be consistent,
but trace points are.
And we'll take a look at each of
these as we explore how to do file
access
observability
and runtime enforcement.
And we're gonna kick things off with
the k probe.
Okay. So let's write our first tracing policy
using a k probe.
Now when you're working with a new Kubernetes
resource,
usually helps to find some examples online or
just use kubectl explain
followed by the name of your resource. Here,
the tracing policy
tells you that we need an API version
kind metadata and spec, but, of course, you
already knew that.
But at the top, we do get the
group, the kind, and the version that we
need to successfully write the start of our
manifest.
So let's do API version,
cilium dot I o b one alpha
one
kind
tracing
policy.
Like everything, we need a metadata with a
name. I'm not fussed what that is. We
leave it like so and then we need
something.
So let's jump back and do kubectl explain
again.
Only this time, we'll add spec.
We can see all of the properties that
our spec can take,
and we're curious about k probes. So we'll
expand that like so.
Now we can see that this is a
list of k probes with an args, a
call,
return return ack, return ack, action, selectors, and
syscall.
So let's start to fill this out.
We know that we have k probes. We
know
it's a list.
It needs some sort of call.
Well, the call is the name of a
function to apply the k probe spec to.
This just means the name of the kernel
function or Cisco that you wanna monitor.
Now we're doing file access stuff today, so
we're gonna take a look at syswrite.
And this is a syscall,
so we're gonna mark this as syscall true.
We know this
because we can see here
that we can specify a billion to indicate
whether this is a function or a syscall
with the syscall being true.
Now, unfortunately, this is not enough for us
to start tracking and observing the syscall with
Tetragon.
We have to provide the RX,
which is a list. Let's jump back to
the terminal.
And we can see the RX here needs
index and it needs type. These are the
two required properties that we need and this
has to describe the function signature
for the kernel function or syscall that you
want to observe.
Now assuming you probably haven't memorized this stuff,
you can look it up on the man
page if you want or it is available
on any good man page website like di.net.
And here we can see the function signature
for the right syscall.
So let's just paste that here for now
and work this out.
So when we did kubectl explain, it said
that we need an index
and a type.
The index just maps through the additive of
the function signature.
Meaning,
we have an index one
and of course zero
and index two
because we have zero, one and two
properties or fields on this function signature.
Now, the type for the first property
is
int because
we have an int.
The type on the second
is charbuff.
Now the c programming language doesn't really have
any concept of strings. It has arrays of
bytes, characters.
When we see this, we do need to
provide a little bit of extra details so
that it understands the size of that property
which is where size args
index comes in.
This is the index
of
account, the size t.
And index two is of type size t
like so.
And now we have enough of a tracing
policy
which I don't know why I called trace
points. Let's call this this
right. In fact, it's not this right. Underscore
right. So let's fix that while we're at
it and we'll even rename the file just
because these things will bug me.
Like so.
Now we have a tracing policy that will
tell us every time the sys write, the
sys call called write is executed within our
kernel.
So let's check.
So we jump over to our terminal.
We're going to do apply on that sys
rate file
where I got a proper entry wrong.
Let's do the explain again, size, arg index,
extra s,
and apply.
And, of course, resource names DNS compatible.
Voila.
Alright. So now we have a tracing
policy.
Wonderful.
So the next thing we want to do
is start pulling out all of the logs
on
our Tetragon pods
so that we can see the feedback, observe
the syscalls within our cluster.
So if we do a cube control
cube system get pods, you'll see that this
is a three node cluster
because we have a daemon set
for Tetragon,
which has three different pods.
So we're gonna get the logs for everything
so that we don't have to chase the
logs that we're looking for.
And to do that, we'll just do a
kube system
logs
dash f
label
app dot Kubernetes IO instance equals
Tetragon.
Now if you remember from the first video,
by default, Tetragon will show you all the
process enter and exits.
So we're just gonna skip past that so
that we can start
to filter on the logs that we care
about.
So I'm gonna split this pane
and we're gonna apply my sleepy
YAML.
A sleepy YAML just runs Ubuntu with a
sleep infinity, but it does mean that we
can exec
into Ubuntu
and run bash.
So as you can see even by just
exec ing into this container, our logs are
already filling up again. So let's just clear
that up.
And now we're going to run echo.
Hello.
And let's write that to this file here.
And we can actually see already we're seeing
our process k probe here
for sys write events
already
because, of course, not all writes happen against
the file system.
So let's write that file.
Now we executed a write, but there's so
much going on. We're actually getting a lot
more writes than we can fully understand, and
it's actually gonna be rather difficult to find
and pinpoint the one event that we want
because let's jump back to here.
When the right syscall is called first,
it writes to a file descriptor
rather than a file name.
So we're not even gonna be able to
see that we wrote to something called DEF
because
at the syscall level there's no such thing.
What we can see and why don't we
just grab
one of these
and throw it into a buffer.
And we'll save this as
output dot JSON and let Versus Code do
some formatting.
So we can see here that we have
some sort of exec ID. Now this looks
like a base 64 encoded string.
Whenever you see one of these,
we can decode it and we see that
this happens on one of our nodes.
No surprise.
We have the path, the UID, the current
directory,
the binary that executed it,
and then we get our logs enriched
web container and Kubernetes information.
Actually, that is pretty sweet.
So we can actually see here from Tetragon
that this pod was the Ubuntu one in
the default namespace with this image that started
here,
its pet is here, it has these labels
and so forth.
So we're already getting a lot more information
from what actually happened in the system.
And if we scroll down, we can actually
see the parent process,
which in this case is run c and
container d that is responsible
for executing a workload.
Now down here, we have the information that
we matched again in our tracing policy.
We can see the syscall, which is sys
write.
Now because these are architecture dependent,
Tetragon has detected the architecture where the pod
is running and prefixed it to get us
the right Cisco.
Thank you, Tetragon.
We can see that we are writing to
fail descriptor two
and here's our bytes.
Again, we have a base 64 encoded string.
Whenever you see one of these, decrypt it.
And we can actually see that we didn't
catch the write that we did with the
echo instead we caught the prompt being written
to my terminal.
We then have the action and the policy
name. So
we need to add a little bit more
information
to our policy so that we're not getting
bombarded with all of this noise.
So let's dive in to selectors.
Okay.
Let's jump back to our terminal,
and we'll close down our Ubuntu for now,
pull up our explain,
and look at k probes.
We can add one more property, which has
our selectors.
And this allows us to add actions, our
explainer capabilities, capability changes, new space changes, new
space puts, and return arcs.
Now we're not gonna sit and dive through
lots more explain commands to understand this. The
Tetragon documentation
is rather good, so it would be a
shame not to use it.
Let's jump over here and we can see
that we have all of the documentation on
the selectors that we can apply to our
tracing policy.
So in order to look at match args,
I've decided to fetch a rather more complete
YAML from
the Tetragon
examples directory.
You can find us on github.com/psyllium/tetragon
and then find the examples folder.
Now this is a really cool example because
it has more k probes.
We're now using kernel functions rather than just
syscalls,
and it already has selectors across each of
these that it's matching against.
And we're gonna take a look at match
args first.
So here,
we're looking for the security path truncate
kernel function.
Now
this has one arg and a return arg,
but how do you get these? Right? There
won't be a man page for every kernel
function.
Well, that's where Sourcegraph comes in if you
wanna make this a bit easier in your
life.
You can use source graph to search the
entire Linux code base.
We can say type
symbol
and copy the function name.
Now we can see the header where this
is defined and the function itself.
In both counts, we see the return value
is an end and it takes some sort
of path
as its only argument.
As such, our is a path and the
return value is an int.
Now because this has taken a path, we
can filter using match args on the first
parameter, the only parameter, and say equals,
etcetera, password.
So let's apply this to our cluster
and pull up our logs.
Let's get rid of all this. And then
instead of splitting this vertically, let's just jump
over to the site where I also have
an Ubuntu bash in this cluster.
And let's check our path, etcetera, password.
Well, let's open them
and add bash one two three.
Now if we pop over here, let's grab
one of our key probes that we can
see
like so.
Let's put this into our output dot JSON
so that we can format it.
We can see here and if you scroll
to the bottom that our security file permission
function was a match for
our Etsy password
file.
So let's tweak our security file permission
selectors.
And instead of just filtering on Etsy password,
let's do a prefix
for everything and say that the Etsy
directory,
like so.
We can then come back across here,
apply,
get our log,
clear the screen
and this time we're right to
LSB release.
Pretend this is a Ubuntu 25.
Now we could pop over here and we'll
see that we still have a k probe
JSON,
like so.
And back to our JSON and paste.
And if we scroll down, it is our
security file permission this time against our Etsy
release. So our prefix is working.
Let's take this one step forward
and
block
any rate access
to this directory.
So back on the selector documentation,
let's go to match actions.
From here, we can do a whole bunch
of things, but the first thing I wanna
show you is sick kill.
This just means stop the process.
Now this example is fortunately exactly what we
want to do. So let's copy our match
action here
and go back to Versus Code.
We come down to the end of our
selectors
and add our match actions,
saying that we want to kill the process
rather than letting it succeed.
So let's apply this to our cluster,
assuming we format it correctly
and get our logs.
So let's open
password,
and it is killed before we even do
anything.
Perfect.
Okay. So the last thing I want to
show you
is one more action.
There's a bunch here that we could work
with,
but I wanna take a look at the
get URL because I think it's quite fun.
So let's copy this
and come back here.
Now instead of killing this,
let's use the get URL action and instead
of going to ebpf.io,
Let's create a box, a request box.
This gives me a URL
like so.
We'll paste this then, go to the terminal
and apply.
Alright.
Let's pull up our logs, not that we
need some really this time
and we delete our swap, and we get
access to the file because this time we
didn't do a kill.
So if we come back over to RBOX
and hit refresh,
you'll see that we got an issue to
be request,
multiple in fact,
letting us know that somebody tried to open
a prefix within that path.
Now a simple GET request in this fashion
is not that immediately
helpful,
but it would allow you to kick off
some sort of Slack driven workflow that post
a message saying that one of your security
profiles failed and maybe you want to start
looking at your logs. Now, of course, there's
other ways to do that, but it's still
fun to think about what ifs. And I
think the get URL is
what if.
So that is our look at file access
permissions with runtime enforcement using Tetragon.
I feel like we've barely scratched the surface.
There is so much awesome things that we
can do with Tetragon.
And
as much as this may inspire you to
go and play with it, and I definitely
encourage you to do so, please remember that
security is an onion. It has many layers.
You're not gonna be able to secure your
systems with 30 lines of YAML.
You need to layer on various syscalls and
functions
and remediation patterns in order to fully protect
and observe your system with a tool like
Tetragon.
But the best time to start is now.
So get it installed.
Start observing special paths within your cluster and
then decide how to act.
Best of luck. We'll be back for part
three of this course as we explore
process
life cycles.
I'll see you then.